meine these heute abend ist die moral
zeit keine miete klimawandel corona
ukraine krieg die großen
gesellschaftlichen debatten unserer zeit
werden mir zu oft mit der moralkeule
geführt persies moral überhaupt nicht
schlecht ist verstehen sie mich nicht
falsch jede gesellschaft braucht für ein
friedliches miteinander bestimmte werte
um ein zusammenleben zu ermöglichen doch
wie mit allem kann man es auch mit der
moral deutlich übertreiben wenn die
moralkeule so häufig geschwungen wird
dass man sich nicht mehr traut seine
meinung zu sagen oder gar fakten
aufzuzeigen dann muss schluss sein für
mich ist absolute moral an vielen
stellen auch einfach schlicht
denkfaulheit es ist faul so moralisch zu
sein hast du keine argumente erklärst du
jede debatte einfach für beendet bevor
sie überhaupt beginnt von der
klimadebatte bis zu corona verschafft
sich der appell an schlechte gewissen
aber auch leichter gehör als sie
trockene darlegung komplexer
sachverhalte aber moral zeit keine miete
wir können selbstverständlich alles
umsetzen was die moral ist in diesem
land vor allem auf twitter so gerne
fordern wir machen das gas embargo gegen
russland für die ukraine wir machen dass
china an war und wegen den uiguren wir
machen den verbrenner des verbrenner
verbot wegen dem weltklima ist atomkraft
verbot wegen der umwelt und
selbstverständlich muss für alle bürger
schnellstens das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen her damit auch der
soziale frieden gewahrt ist wenn wir das
aber alles machen sind wir zwar
moralisch die gewinner aber arm was wir
lernen die moral zeit keine miete ich
finde wir brauchen stattdessen
pragmatische zielorientierte politik das
ziel muss sein deutschen bürgern ein
möglichst gutes umfeld für ein sicheres
leben und stetig steigenden wohlstand zu
ermöglichen und damit beende ich jetzt
auf meinem monolog und eröffne die runde
alexander kissler wie sehen sie das ja
wie sehe ich das also den grund impuls
kann ich natürlich verstehen dass man
sagt moralkeule werden wenn ich keine
argumente habe sage ich du bist ein
schlechter mensch du hast die fallen die
eisbären sterben ja das habe ich auch
schon ein buch dagegen geschriebener
infantile gesellschaft sondern über die
moral vor sich her trägt aber ich glaube
wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
moralismus und vernunft und es kann auch
bei einigen der beispiele die jetzt hier
genannt worden sind ja durchaus
vernünftig sein dass man im sinne seiner
eigenen moral sein eigenes verhalten
überprüft wenn ich zum beispiel höhere
jetzt eben gas-embargo sollen wir gar
nicht 3 denken obwohl putin einen krieg
angezettelt hat denn er vielleicht als
gas embargo herr kessler ich bin dafür
dass man das gas embargo energisch
diskutiert dass ein eventuell ist auch
macht denn ich muss gespenst das weiß
ich nicht das nicht umsetzbar ist ich
bin auf jeden fall einen einsatz noch
dazu ein wir müssen glaube ich schauen
dass wir das kind nicht mit dem bade
ausschütten also ich glaube wir dürfen
nicht unmoralisch werden in unserem haus
auf moralismus also wir müssen uns schon
auch die traute haben zu entscheidungen
zu kommen die andere ablehnen und dann
auch für den preis für diese
entscheidung zu stehen und das meint er
nur moral moralismus ist falsch nach
gute moral gebrochen war ja ich glaube
die wahrheit liegt in der mitte es gibt
eine ganze reihe von punkten wo wir aber
feststellen müssen dass das
wirtschaftsmodell deutschlands sich ein
stück weit überholt hat gerade gas aus
russland oder fossile energien sind ja
ein klassisches beispiel dass wir china
als so einen starken starken absatzmarkt
erschlossen haben ist auf der einen
seite gut aber auch dann sehen wir was
jetzt passiert wenn eine diktatur hier
so sich aufführt wie wir das eigentlich
ja quasi parallel buch erwarten und
dementsprechend ist es sicherlich
richtig dass man an der einen stelle
dann auch ein wirtschaftsmodell
umsteuert auf der anderen seite sind
natürlich themen wie kernenergie gerade
zur jetzigen zeit ein thema was man
diskutieren muss und sicherlich kann man
über fusionsenergie sprechen wir wollen
uns ja weiterentwickeln wir wollen das
land zukunftsfähig machen warum wir
nicht über fusionsenergie
forschungsreaktor der entschluss steht
der soll hoffentlich in mitte der 30er
jahre genug energie sauber und sicher
produzieren dass wir ein thema wo man
diskutieren sollte sowas wie
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen etc muss
man ablehnen es kann keinen wohlstand
quasi ohne leistung geben sonst und
deswegen werden wir das sicherlich so
auch nicht umsetzen ganz egal was auf
twitter anfang juli ich meine die fdp
ist auch in der regierung daher ich
solche töne nicht und seine freunde doch
wir haben noch eine runde formen und da
wir haben wir haben schon wir haben ja
schon gesagt
der der faktor wird auch weiter über die
europäische union finanziert haben auch
von deutschland wir haben klar gesagt
die zukunft deutschlands liegt
quasi darin dass wir stärker in
forschung investieren dass wir nach
vorne gucken dass wir unser
wirtschaftsmodell entsprechend erneuern
und das müssen wir in der konstellation
der wir jetzt regieren sicherlich auch
vielleicht jeden tag jede woche neue
verteidigen aber das werden wir tun
dafür sind wir menschen die umfragewerte
für die fdp nicht so gut aber ich würde
auch gern eine frage an frau
arbeitsstellen bevor wir dazu kommen
robert tragen sie eigentlich noch pelz
würden sie sich trauen auch alten pelz
zu tragen moralisch hat man da
eigentlich nichts gegen einzuwenden das
tier ist eh schon tot ja also ich habe
ein paar pilze im schrank ich hatte zwei
jahren nicht getragen
und bin fast so weit dass sie
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht mehr
trage aber ich war eine der letzten die
die pelze im schrank lässt in hamburg
nie bei mir pelz in münchen vielleicht
noch etwas mehr ja es ist auch auf
daunenjacken sind in und es ist ein aber
sie würden sich trauen also ist nicht
wegen der moral in der villa ist einfach
nicht mehr für mich ist es ist out und
macht altes predigen andere schon lange
ich fand es immer noch schick es waren
ja auch junge pelze und modische pelze
ich habe die auch verkauft sehr gut
verkauft sogar aber irgendwann bin sogar
ich jetzt dazu gekommen dass ich sie
eher nicht mehr trage deshalb da ich
aber ein sehr wankelmütige mensch bin
und der mode unterliege das kann bei der
nächsten kälte schon wieder anders
aussehen vor allen dingen an der
fußboden kalt ist ja dann legt er meine
pelze drauf gut da sind die plätze nach
hinten da muss man auch mal
im fußball herr dohrendorf wenn sie
meinem ein monolog war sehr vorstand
angehört habe der moral gibt es denn
etwas wo sie sagen die moralkeule ist
schon bei einigen debatten zu stark da
ja das ist ja immer so ein großes
problem das ist ja auch nachher so ein
bisschen mein thema so diese mainstream
politik dass man einfach am liebsten
vorher nach meinungsforschung ist
gefragt kommt das andere da kommt ein
moralisches beispiel ein praktisches wo
sie merken im alltag da fühle ich mich
jetzt bei mir geht es beim klimawandel
so damit das gefühl dass es keine
rationale diskussion möglich gutes
beispiel es wurde ja gerade im januar
von der neuen regierung dargestellt dass
wir bis 2030 6006 millionen
wärmepumpen umsetzen wollen wenn man
sich dann mit den praktikern die das
umsetzen müssen wo das nadelöhr
eigentlich ist das sind die handwerker
die brauchen dafür 60.000 monteure also
wir können jetzt mal fragen ob wir
irgendwann irgendwo haben wir brauchen
60 zusätzlich also der notdienst denn
der der der neubau ist noch gar nicht
mit berücksichtigt das weiß man
eigentlich jetzt schon und trotzdem hat
man so ein wettbewerb der klimaziele
jeder etwas schneller und besser werden
aber man kann es gar nicht umsetzen man
streut eigentlichen bürgern und bürger
wirklich sand in die augen und das finde
ich schade und dann wundert man sich
dass es eine politikverdrossenheit gibt
in drei jahren aber da schon weiß wie
reicht uns eh nicht und das ist ein
schwieriges thema und da würde ich halt
einfach viel stärker eine klare kante
zeigen wir brauchen auch einfach wieder
dinge wo man den hand wer den den auch
den politiker so richtig stellen kann
damit er auch mal eine richtige mann
ich versuche es ja auch das
kinderschutzgesetz hat doch die cdu
geführte bundesregierung davor so
verabschiedet heißt die grundlagen für
genau diese klimaziele jetzt auch
umgesetzt werden müssen hat angela
merkel hat die cdu hat auf europäischer
ebene eine cdu-politikerin frau von der
leyen maßgeblich mit ihren hab dich
gemacht dass tatsächlich jemand richtig
aber deswegen kann man jetzt glaube ich
im januar wenn man auf januar 2022 geht
nicht das ganze diskutieren ohne zu
sehen was in den letzten 16 jahren
erfolg ist vor allem letzten acht jahren
und das natürlich die ampelkoalition
mit unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten der
einzelnen akteure hier zu einem
koalitionsvertrag gekommen ist wo die
grünen einen schwerpunkt haben wo die
fdp ein schwerpunkt hat die spd einen
schwerpunkt hat das ist so wir hätten
vielleicht auch eine jamaika
konstellation stärker von das ging mit
der union leider nicht aber deswegen
auch da würde ich glauben müssen wir am
ende sagen wir haben uns alle auf die
klimaziele 2050 verständigt das war ein
langer prozess und jetzt müssen wir
sehen wie wir es umsetzen und natürlich
ist es richtig dass sachen die
unrealistisch sind die nicht gehen auch
entsprechend dann gebrannt war
gebrandmarkt werden müssen und darüber
diskutiert werden muss ich glaube da
sind wir alle aufgerufen genau das zu
tun aber er war nicht deutschland
erwärmung schon dann erbt er wäre es
nützlich sind für uns kleine zelle hier
deutschland ja für diesen kleine land
wenn um uns herum alles anders läuft es
kalt lassen ja aber die ganze
europäische union hat sich auf einen
klima neutralität verpflichtet das muss
man zur kenntnis nehmen ja ja das haben
wir wie gesagt das hat die
vorgängerregierung
ganz ganz fleißig atomkraftwerke und wer
nicht und das ist ja bei
grün los atomkraft ausgestiegen ist die
union so
stark sein
diese russland geschäft in der energie
gemacht und ja damals nicht so schlimm
ja wer kann das ahnen wenn dich dein
ehemann geld sicher stich du warst 30 er
glücklich verheiratet und sagen
passieren im leben das ist ja
ich will eigentlich auf seiner grundlage
nicht politik für deutschland machen
aber sie haben gerade hat gerade gesagt
ja die regierung hat das und ich könnte
doch nicht doch ich kann ich sage das
was ich wir können ja wir können ich
konnte es leider nicht anders
beeinflusst dass ich richtig gibt ja
ich habe auch ich musste mich auch
festhalten nimmt er neben jahren ist ja
ja ja obwohl ich auch gar nicht die
hochgefahren ist das sagen hat man muss
einfach das sagen können und auch wenn
die die regierung davor war ja nicht nur
die die die cdu ja auch die spd dabei
atomkraft ist nicht nur die cdu
ausgestiegen das hat er nicht gemacht so
trotzdem kann ich sagen ich das was
einfach gerade falsch läuft und das ist
gerade im januar 22 von ihrer region er
verkündet worden wir wollen das und
jetzt und man weiß jetzt schon dass ist
nicht erreichbar und das ist nicht
richtig aber das ist das gleiche da
haben wir jetzt sich beispiele aber sie
tun ja gerade so als ob man das nicht
sagen darf gerade über präsident gerade
sogar gesagt gerade wenn man in der
atomkraft redet wir haben jetzt gerade
den haushalt für das jahr 20 22 im
bundestag beschlossen haben zum beispiel
kollegen von mir aus der fdp gesagt dass
man darüber diskutieren muss dass man
die laufzeiten der kernkraftwerke noch
am netz sind verlängert das wird
diskutiert
das ist ein debattenbeitrag das kann
jeder sagen da kann jeder an ecken da
sind vielleicht koalitionspartner der
fdp nicht ganz so glücklich wenn das im
deutschen bundestag formuliert wird das
gehört dazu also deswegen denkverbote
gibt es nicht